Zipping through the streets.
Blocking the sidewalks.
Dockless electric scooters have appeared virtually
overnight in dozens of cities.
So far this year, millions of rides were taken
on little machines just like this.
And their operators have raised billions in
investments.
So if you haven’t yet, chances are you're going to
see stuff like this pretty soon.
We see the scooters navigating through pedestrians.
We see them being left anywhere.
And this creates problems for a number of
people.
Problems indeed.
If people on dockless scooters or bikes keep
using the sidewalks … it’s going to get
crowded.
the purpose of the sidewalk has changed considerably
over the last 100 years.
when cities first started building sidewalks,
the reason for them was to accommodate pedestrians
on the street.
But this was not the only use of sidewalks.
A lot of that happens before the automobile.
Here’s a street scene from San Francisco
in 1906.
Notice the man, holding a baby, just, walking
straight through traffic.
Nobody seems too concerned. they are quite
relaxed about it and they also know how to
navigate the street.
But, eventually cars got bigger and faster.
Traffic had to separate.
We start seeing with the proliferation
of the cars, many many cities start widening
their streets.
and of course this happens at the expense
of the sidewalk because a lot of times the
buildings were pretty much set.
So a sidewalk that was 10 — 12 feet becomes 6 — 8 feet.
Which is pretty unfair for pedestrians.
Because there is a lot more happening on sidewalks
than walking.
There’s the frontage zone
— in cities, a business might put a cafe
or signs here.
Then there’s the furniture zone, full of
streetlights, newspaper racks, and benches.
Because sidewalks have frontage and furniture zones, there's less space to travel than it might seem.
Some vigilantes have taken the space issue into their own hands
And many cities have used pilot programs to really get the scooters
under control.These pilots are likely to extend.
After all, cities need alternative modes of
transportation.
First it takes vehicles off the street
Because people who might be using ride hail,
or taxis, or another personal vehicle, might
instead opt for
this other solution
if a person takes a subway or a bus to a certain
station or stop, and they still live a mile
away from that station, they have to figure
out how to get there
Even in cities with exceptional levels of
public transportation, many residents have
to travel a ‘last mile’
If dockless vehicles are deployed in areas
like this, residents could have more options
for transportation.
And not just rely on cars.
Because what many people will do is say
‘I don’t have a last mile option that
works for me.
I’m just going to drive the whole way.
The cash influx for scooter-share is a really
a bet.
Investors hope that e-scooters can capture
demand in underserved transportation deserts,
without adding congestion
And the scooters might pull that off.
One survey found robust support for e-scooters
as a substitute for short driving trips, or
as a complement to public transit.
But the scooters won’t work if their riders
have to compete for space with pedestrians
and cars.
we’re reaching a point in cities across
america, where it’s time to get people out
of their cars and allow people more modes.
Smaller transportation — bikes, segways,
scooters — they only work when cities make
space for them.
Planners can do this by designing ‘complete
streets’.
So complete streets is a new term that entered
the lexicon of planning and transportation
planning relatively recently.
but basically it is inspired by earlier streets
where you used to have all these different
uses social uses of the streets and sidewalks
not only vehicular users
Complete streets start by reducing the amount
of space given to cars.
Making space for protected bus bulbs, wider
sidewalks, street level plazas, and buffered
bike lanes.
Scooters will be a more realistic last mile
option when cities build networks of complete
streets.
So, worry not, dear pedestrians — even if
the scooters are here to stay…
Cities are drafting standards for this brave
new world of alternative transportation.
With any luck, the love for scooters just
might push cities to invest in safer, more
accomodating streets.
Hi, thanks for watching and a special thanks
to the University of California for hitting
the streets to help us make this episode.
They also partnered with us on our Climate
Lab series, check out this video about the
environmental effects of online shopping.